Independence Day resurgence was supposed
to kick start a whole new franchise in
2016 but a third movie hasn't
materialized since then and they're
likely never well he is why the
Independence Day series has finished for
good while boasting an ensemble cast the
familiar faces like Jeff Goldblum and
Bill Pullman the breakout star of
Independence Day was Will Smith
welcome to earth up to that point Smith
was best known for his recording career
and TVs Fresh Prince of Bel Air but this
movie established him as a bonafide
movie star for years afterwards Smith
virtually owned Independence Day weekend
at the box office
starring in a string of early July
blockbusters that included men in black
bad boys - and Hancock
by the time Independence Day resurgence
began production nearly twenty years
later Smith was too busy to return to
the franchise that helped make him such
a screen idol I had a couple of films
lined up I had concussion and Suicide
Squad and so it was really it was a
decision you know timing wise between
Independence Day and Suicide Squad in
retrospect that was kind of a no-win
scenario resurgence to screenwriters
revised a film script to explain the
absence of Smith's character captain
Steven Hiller killing him off screen
before the events of the sequel that
creative decision effectively preclude
Smith from returning for any future
movies and without its biggest most
bankable star why keep the franchise
going when a movie makes a ton of money
at the box office it makes sense to make
a sequel in a hurry while audiences fund
the memories of the movie afresh this
didn't happen with Independence Day the
first film was a top grosser of 1996
breaking in 306 million dollars but the
sequel hit theaters in 2016 a full 20
years later barely clearing 100 million
dollars of the American box office
against the reported production costs of
165 million dollars making things worse
the people that saw resurgence generally
didn't care for it in a master Rotten
Tomatoes audience score of just 30
percent slightly better than his 29
percent rating from critics a review in
Entertainment Weekly gave the film an F
calling it quote disposable and
shockingly inept in the end Fox lost too
much money and audience goodwill and
resurgence to proceed with the sequel
getting the message that people weren't
interested
the original Independence Day is full of
talented actors but aside from Will
Smith it's not exactly a roster of movie
stars actors like Bill Pullman Randy
Quaid brent Spiner and vivica a fox make
for a deep bench of these movies casts
but on their own
none of them can carry a big-budget
sci-fi extravaganza not even Jeff
Goldblum
while they make for a strong and sambal
in the original movie these actors have
mostly faded from the limelight since
the first Independence Day was released
the new young additions to the cast also
failed to fill the gap in star power
including Liam Hemsworth best known for
supporting work in The Hunger Games and
being related to Thor unless her
producers wanted to make a third movie
or for reboots that's the cast the movie
would have to work with and as the box
office returns for resurgence makes
clear audiences aren't eager to show up
to see them with or without the original
cast another movie would be a big risk
Independence Day came to fruition thanks
to a team up between filmmakers Dean
Devlin and Roland Emmerich a duo
co-wrote the script with Devlin
producing and Emmerich directing both
returned for resurgence but it doesn't
look like that will happen again at
least not for Devlin throwing an
appearance at WonderCon in 2018 the
filmmaker was quoted as saying currently
I personally have no plans on doing
another one a few weeks later he
solidified his departure on the Matthew
Aaron Show podcast saying he was backing
away from working with major studios
after the failure of the 2017 movie geo
storm as a result he excused himself
from both more Independence Day and a
reboot of its other big franchise
stargates with one of the chief minds
behind the movies now out of the running
the future of Independence Day seems
unstable if not non-existent the first -
Independence Day films were productions
from 20th Century Fox a studio which was
swallowed up in a 71 point three billion
dollar acquisition by Disney in early
2019
that means Disney is now calling the
shots behind the scenes in total control
of our Studios old franchises including
Avatar Deadpool and Independence Day two
of those a billion dollar franchises and
one isn't according to The Wall Street
Journal the new bosses are significantly
ramping down Fox's movie production
especially when it comes to expensive
projects that are family-friendly or
guaranteed franchise builders that
spells bad news for another visit to
this particular well Disney's having a
hard enough time keeping interest in
Star Wars going and that's one of the
most popular franchises of all time do
you really think they're gonna sink any
work into a risky third installment or
the Independence Day series in the
absence of viewers demanding gear it
looks like there's no chance we will
go quietly into the night we will not
finish without a fight
we're going to live on we're going to
survive
yeah actually maybe no check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos but your favorite
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]